welcome back let's go back to the phones
we'll go to our next caller from the
let's go to the six one nine area code
let's start there six one nine who maybe
is doing dishes or something like that
hope you can hear me who's this hey this
is Doug first-time caller I'm a Trump
supporters and I just want to say that I
I see your Oprah I fear Oprah's I see
the one person that could be Trump but
the good news is the Democratic
establishment and the DNC and even
Elizabeth Warren came out today they
don't want her so the one person that
could beat Trump the Democratic
establishment is rejecting I just love
that I read this it's just good news for
Trump yeah there you go so you're happy
I'm happy I hope I just hope they keep
rejecting her the only way which it
would happen if there's a massive
groundswell support to push Elizabeth
Warren all the Democrat wannabes to the
side and just say put over there but I
don't think that's gonna happen so
Trump's good for 20 22 24 there you go
well if the Democrats hopefully the
Democrats are taking advice from you
because you seem to know how it's gonna
go hey where's your accent from is that
is that like a mid Upper Midwest thing
no I've been in the republic of Amul I'm
sorry where are you the Republic of them
all I'm rule yeah I want to know that is
Oh many we know you NIT
each County or San Diego it's the last
vesting of republicanism in those state
of California okay hey so what are you
pleased with what Trump's done so far I
am pleased with Allah he does but the
wall has to be built well be the deal
breaker if the border wall is not built
there would be such a backlash it won't
like why both for Republicans if they
can't get the wall done you know I the
wall has to be built and it has to be
built by realm so like Doug if Donald
Trump doesn't build the wall by the 2020
election will you punish him by not
voting for him no it's gonna get done
before it's gonna get done before 2020
okay no but Doug why don't you let me
right I know what happened in the White
House hold on a second hold on a second
ugh if I can what I said was not do you
think it'll happen before 2020 if we get
to November of 2020 and it hasn't been
built will you say I can't vote for
Trump for re-election because he didn't
do that thing that I said is the most
important thing it depends what happens
he can't cave in to the Democrats
demands he's the block the border wall
has to be built
he can't say we're gonna do dock over
we're gonna keep chain migration we're
gonna do all that yeah and comprehensive
immigration reform without building the
wall so let me see if I can ask the
question a different way Doug if he
doesn't build the wall by 2020 will you
still vote for him ah yes depending on
the circumstances yes so in other words
it actually doesn't matter whether he
builds the wall to secure your vote for
2020 even though I hold on a second hold
on a second you said first that the most
important thing is he's got to build the
wall but now you're saying you would
vote for him in 2020 without the wall so
how important is the wall really yes
like and I clarified my statement I i
amplified it so you would be more to be
more specific because you're asking more
specific questions so yes under certain
circumstances I would still vote for
them if the circumstances were such as a
negative consequences then I probably
want it but I'm pretty sure things are
going to go our way and I'm gonna get
two thousand eight hundred dollars in a
tax Trump tax refund check here hold on
a second
let your all look here's what I'm trying
to figure out if you'd vote for Trump
whether he builds the wall or not then
why would he even go through the trouble
of building it he's got your vote either
way no no no he does I just gave you
specifics I just gave you Pacific's if
if if he caves into the Democrats demand
of no dhaka chain migration
comprehensive immigration full refund
without the border wall
security without the border of being
belt that is a deal-breaker okay okay I
know how much more clear I gotta be
that's a deal-breaker
hey last thing Doug what has Trump
already done that you really like oh I
love just about hahaha what hasn't he
literally does the executive orders to
end all Obama's legacy on business
regulations like which regulations
attack all of them what's an example
that you like that one Doug hold on a
second
but you which regulations on businesses
that Obama put in that yet a bomber
touched that was that business was it
with the destruction to the to the mark
Doug hold on a second you're shot out of
a cannon today Doug can you tell me a
particular business regulation that
you're glad is gone under Trump a
capital gains what changed with capital
gains well get chapel gates it's got to
go down for corporate corporations
capital gains for corporation
corporations don't pay capital gains
capital gains is something individual
taxpayers pay so corporations pay
capital gains tax all right Doug thanks
for the call really appreciate it
folks this is who we're fighting against
okay this is who we're fighting against
and it's California right just get five
other people to vote that you're not
going to convince that guy